that was Chris Pratt starring as Mario
in the new Super Mario Brothers movie
privilege of seeing oh yeah
oh and I was so excited I love it I love
you and Anya Taylor Joy together too
thank you Princess Peach Princess Peach
of course yeah and we've got uh Jack
Black plays Bowser uh Charlie Day Place
Charlie Day plays Luigi Seth Rogen is
Donkey Kong
it's excellent well in honor of that
will you play uh Truth or Dare it's a
gaming play here because we pun my name
with everything
[Applause]
Truth or Dare let's go
two boxes go for it do I come down here
wherever you want okay I want to do
truth
all done oh okay okay perfect
everyone loves Mario Kart what gives you
road rage for me just inconsiderate
drivers in general in California I don't
know if it's the same way out here but
it seems you put your blinker on and
that means to the person behind you oh I
better speed up
he wants the road in front of me no oh
it makes me mad
You Know Who You Are
another dream another truths
if you could eat a magic mushroom I'll
do it
oh it's not that's it's a two-parter
that could only grow one body part what
would it be yeah
oh more hair more hair can I just like
lower this like an inch yeah I'm gonna
turn my five head into a forehead
let's go get that going okay one last
one
oh this is a dare oh it is yeah
put on some overalls and do your best
runway walk
we do have a catwalk here
accepted
I happen to have a pair right here
look at that
I'll do I'll do what I do for my kids oh
my gosh
get the get that I don't get to take my
shoe off no we're gonna make this work
no can I keep these yeah these are nice
I noticed that
hey
they actually work wow I saw you on the
tractor in them
and then if you come this way when I do
a cowboy
ready
[Music]
work
[Applause]
all right
have you heard of the comedy Legend
Mitzi banana more oh I've been dying to
meet Mitzi you have I
I don't know I could find out
we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]